india's health services are being
overwhelmed so many patients are
seriously ill with kovid that patients
are being treated in ambulances
hospitals are running out of beds oxygen
is in critically short supply and
doctors are having to choose who to
treat
it's a desperate situation for the
people who are watching that patient
deteriorate in front of their own eyes
and it's an equally desperate situation
for us because
how we wish we can take every patient
who requires to be in the hospital just
get them in and offer them care just 10
percent of the population has been
vaccinated a new variance of the virus
is spreading rapidly including one with
a worrying double mutation
yet there is still no national lockdown
and public health experts have
criticized the government for allowing
events like a major hindu festival to go
ahead
all possible super spreader events
including large gatherings indoor or
outdoor should have been avoided
but uh whether it was elections to the
local bodies or to the assemblies or
the may last religious gatherings and of
course
large-scale celebration of social events
like weddings and so on
all of them have compounded the problem
in the uk those with friends and
relatives in india are anxious
ash is a student his mum back home has
been seriously ill with covid for more
than a week
how are you feeling now
when she told him a few days ago that
she feared for her life his instinct was
to fly home
but he can't because india is about to
go on the red list it has been getting
worse and worse
and like knowing that she's sick and
seeing that there's an oxygen oxygen
shortage
there is a rain deserve like which is
total drug shortage
and i was like if she gets worse what's
next like how will she get him
and that's why he wants to go yeah yeah
like i wanted to make sure like by any
means i am there
and i can provide for her but he just
couldn't yeah
i couldn't at heathrow the last flights
from india
are arriving before the new travel
restrictions come into force on friday
india's surge is causing alarm worldwide
and the uk isn't alone in bringing in
rules to stop
cases and new variants from spreading
thomas more sky news